Voiceover: In all of our conversations
about demand curves so far,
I've been generally talking about
price driving quantities.
So for example, we've been saying,
using say this demand curve right here
for a new car in terms of how many
would be sold per day,
we would say things like,
"Well look, if we price
it at $60,000 per car,"
this is in thousands of dollars.
"If we price it at $60,000 per car,
"we are going to sell one car.
"If we price it at $50,000 a car,
"we are going to sell two cars."
The way that I've been talking about
it is given a price,
how many are we actually going to sell?
What I want to do in this video
is think about it the other way around.
We're going to look at the
exact same demand curve,
the exact same relationship
between price and quantity,
but we're going to conceptualize
it in our heads in a
slightly different way.
We're going to think about it in terms
of quantity driving price.
To think of it that way,
imagine that we are the producers
of this given model of a new car.
We go the other way.
We don't say, "How many will we sell
"at a price of $60,000?"
Or, "How much will we sell
at a price of $50,000?"
We'll go from the point of view
of what if we only produce one car a week?
If we only produced one car a week,
how much could we get for that car?
Let's say somehow you're
able to figure that out.
You're able to read people's minds
or you have some type of a market study.
When you ask that question you're like,
"Look if you only allowed
one car to be sold each week,
"you determine that in that week there
"is going to be somebody,
"somebody's going to think that it's worth
"$60,000 to buy that car."
That person, they're willingness to pay,
that person is going to be
willing to trade $60,000.
They're going to be willing to forego
what else they could have bought
for that $60,000 and
instead they want that car.
Then you would plot that
point right over there.
If you only had one unit, you
could sell it for $60,000.
Now let's go, let's keeping
asking ourselves for more units.
Let's say, what if we
wanted to sell two units?
Well, if you wanted to sell two units,
you could definitely sell
one unit for $60,000,
assuming that you could
get that first person,
but that second person,
this might have been the person that
just wants a car so
badly it just resonated
with them in some way.
For that second unit,
the second person who is
going to need to buy your car,
might not be as excited about it.
That second person will only be willing
to forego $50,000.
That second person would
be willing to forego 50.
So if you wanted to sell two units,
if you insist on selling two units,
and if you're assuming you're going
to give the same price for everyone.
We'll talk about in the future
how you might give different prices
to different people.
Assuming you want to give
the same price to everyone,
you're going to have to
sell your car for $50,000.
Now clearly that first
person is definitely
going to jump at it.
They're going to be able
to get the car for more
than they were willing to pay.
More than what it was worth to them.
More than the benefit for them,
but if you want two people,
now you're going to have
to set this up for $50,000.
Now the same logic.
Now what if we want to sell three cars?
What if we want to sell three cars a week?
Well, if we price it at $50,000,
we'll definitely get those first two,
but the third person might not jump.
The third person isn't
going to be as excited
about it or need it as
much as these first two.
So you do a market study
or you're able to read
people's minds.
You're like, "Look the third person,
"for the market, the marginal benefit."
Let me write this word down.
The marginal benefit.
The marginal benefit for the next unit,
the next unit is going to be $40,000.
To get that next buyer,
and it could be multiple buyers
buying each unit or it could be one buyer
buying all of the units.
Maybe it's some type of a
car rental company saying,
"Oh, we don't need to get ... For three
"of these cars I'm not as
excited about it anymore.
"My marginal benefit is lower."
This is really the same marginal benefit
that we talked about when
we talked about the PPF,
the Production Possibilities Frontier.
In that, we talked
about it very explicitly
in terms of trade off,
in terms of opportunity cost.
Here we're measuring the marginal benefit
in terms of price,
but price really can be viewed
as a foregone opportunity.
If you spend $40,000 on this car,
you're making the decision
not to spend $40,000
on something else.
A down payment on a house or a nice boat,
or whatever else it might be.
So really what we're doing,
is at any point in this curve,
this really is the marginal benefit
for that next buyer.
That marginal benefit to the market
of that next unit of
whatever you are producing.
This is a very different way of viewing
the exact same demand curve.
Before we said, "Okay, if we want to price
"it at $50,000, how many
are we going to sell?"
Now we're saying, "If we
want to sell only two units,
"where can we price it?"
We can price it at $50,000.
If we want to go from two to three units,
we're going to have to price it
at the marginal benefit of that third unit
to the market and it could be the marginal
benefit to that next consumer.
Convincing that next consumer to say,
"Hey it is worth it to buy this car.
"Let's price it at $40,000."
I'm going to leave you
there in this video,
but what I'm going to think about
is depending on where you price it,
let's say that we decide that we
want to sell four units every week.
So we say, "Well look, to get that fourth
"person to buy this car,
we have to price the car
"at $30,000."
What we're going to talk about in the next
video is if you did that,
if this is where you decide to price it
so that you can sell four units,
these other people got really good deals.
The first unit could
have gone for much more.
The second unit could have still also
gone for a good bit,
not as much as the first unit.
The third unit could
have gone for a little
bit less than the second unit,
but still more than what you
ended up selling things for.
We're going to talk about this idea
right over here that some of these
consumers are getting more for their money
than what they have to pay,
or at least in their own minds they are.